well
it's good to be back on campus
oh this is nice last time I was in this
room I was to cry EBD ass right over
there
well the entire reset board stat here
and tried to explain why it was that
Israel deserve divestment but Iran
didn't the University for providing all
of the security arrangements which does
more to allow more people in the room
because one of the issues that we had
here tonight was that they wanted to
make sure that everybody was registered
so when they had turned away several
hundred people a little bit earlier
there were about fourteen hundred people
who signed up who couldn't come
apparently but hopefully that can be
rectified next time I haven't actually
seen this many police officers since the
UCLA basketball team went shopping for
sunglasses come to think of it last time
I went here so nothing has changed it
seems and in the last listen I graduated
2004 so in the last 13 years I'm always
grateful to UCLA as an institution I
graduated from here it allowed me to go
on and do I think important things my
wife graduated from UCLA she graduated
from UCLA Medical School my sister
graduated from UCLA so this definitely
is our home school ok so I want to talk
a little bit about the rise of campus
fascism and why that fascism seems to
have come almost solely from the left
here on campus Snowden's model and some
people on the Left are familiar with to
discuss what exactly fascism constitutes
in 1950 there was a Marxist theorist his
name was Theodore Adorno his member of
the so-called Frankfurt School the
Frankfurt School is a group of
expatriate German intellectuals with the
Marxist bent they left in the late 1920s
early 1930s from Germany to come to the
United States trying to flee the the
rising tide of hitlerism and Adorno
along with a couple of other University
of Berkeley researchers that he wrote a
book called the authoritarian
personality and this book has become
sort of a hallmark in in the literature
of authoritarianism in terms of fascism
people have used this book to describe
what makes somebody authoritarian
Adorno's theory was basically that
individuals who have fistic tendencies
also tend to come from authoritarian
backgrounds or tend to hold
authoritarianism
now some of this has been proved to be a
little bit flawed but the general
framework is not entirely wrong when it
comes to describing a certain mindset
that exists among people were more
likely to want to quash dissent the
problem for eduardo is that because
Adorno was a member of the left he was
deliberately trying to obfuscate the
fascism that so often comes from the
left he was trying to define fascism in
a way that actually excluded people of
the left so never mind that Hitler and
the Nazis were technically if he would
put them on the american political
spectrum there of the american left
there of the european right because
europe doesn't operate according to the
same guidelines that the united states
does so in Germany Hitler's movement was
of the right because it was in contrast
to the Marxist left but if you moved
Hitler's centralized government
perspective everything from health care
to finance into the spectrum of American
politics he'd actually end up somewhere
on the American left but Adorno felt the
necessity to draw a hard distinction
between hitlerism and Marxism and so his
description of what authoritarianism was
excluded authoritarianism of the left
but if you remove some of the some of
the leftist bias of his descriptions
what makes for an authoritarian
personality it's a pretty good look at
why people attempt to shut down today
what exactly makes somebody want to go
out there and violently protest not just
go out there and protest like I guess
there maybe 15 people out there tonight
doing that but it did not those people
are fine I mean the Democratic
socialists of America o'mine of them I
hope they're having fun but I'm glad
that some of you showed up by the way
thank you for showing up it you know
quick show of hands - I want to give a
round of applause to people who show up
who disagree with me before we start how
many people here disagree with me just
to start thank you for coming I
appreciate
it does take some it does take some guts
to actually come to an arena where most
of the crowds gonna disagree with you
where the speaker is going to disagree
with you and actually come to discuss
and debate the issues as opposed to
going outside and carrying around signs
and making lots of noise and pretending
you're important so I want to go through
Adorno's authoritarian personality I'm
gonna go through what he thought were
two sort of benign elements of what
makes someone authoritarian this is
called the California f-scale is really
what it's called because called a
fascist scale and there's a professor
named Adrian Burnham it's a professor of
psychology at the university college and
loves and he's broken it down into these
nine elements so let's strip these
elements as their leftist bias and then
we can talk about how they apply on
today's campuses so the first element is
what this professor and what is Wornall
called conventionalism rigid adherence
to conventional middle-class values so
for example obedience and respect for
authority are the most important virtues
children should learn now obviously
consider these rather left-leaning
perspective on how children ought to be
raised the idea that children the
obedience is not necessary in children
as the father of a three and a half year
old and one and a half year old I can
promise you that that my
authoritarianism goes without question
in my house at least for there at least
for their ages because if it didn't they
would be done I mean that's just the way
that it works particularly with young
children if they don't listen to you
then they kill themselves there they are
very difficult to handle but with all of
that said this idea that conventionalism
is restricted to people of the right the
conventionalism is just about booyah
middle-class values is just not true
conventionalism is about adhering to the
moral standard that is promulgated at
the time so on campus conventionalism is
not of the right right I'm at the center
here now normally across America if I'm
in Alabama that I'm a conventionalist
right if I'm in Texas I'm a
conventionalist
although in fire in Alabama I wouldn't
vote for Roy Moore but if I but if I
were but conventionalism depends on
where you are at the time so if you're
inside the institution like UCLA where
the conventional view is a very
left-leaning one then your orthodoxy of
obedience to Authority is conventional
so if you believe that the campus has to
be ruled from above by the
administrators who are going to tell you
what's right and wrong you are
conventionalist right so the inherited
values are not conventional middle class
ones here on college campuses they are
inherited values of the left and as you
see here on campus Oh
and respect for authority to the left is
required if you dissent then it is very
likely three and four times they attempt
to impose a policy where we have to pay
a specific security fee if less than 70%
of the people who show up in a crowd are
from the University campus three out of
three of the four times that policies
haven't been used it'll be used against
the dissenters because obedience to the
left obedience to Authority is key
so obviously this elements of
authoritarianism exists on the left on
college campuses second element is
authoritarian Submission uncritical
acceptance of authority so this
professor writes young people sometimes
get rebellious ideas but as they grow up
they ought to oh what they ought to get
over them and settle down so this ties
in with this peculiar perspective that
is arisen on some parts of the the more
mainstream left now particularly on
campuses that dissent is violence that
speech is violence when I was at
Berkeley there's actually crowd outside
literally chanting speeches violence
right that there's this uncritical
acceptance of the authority structure
and if I did not accept that authority
structure I was committing an act of
verbal terrorism this is why there's
always an attempt to shut me down when I
come on campus because the idea is that
the things that I say are so inherently
dangerous they're so dangerous and so
scary that they provide a challenge to
the existing mode of authority I mean I
sort of hope they do but they aren't
that dangerous okay none of my followers
have gone out and beaten anyone up none
of my followers have gone out and killed
anyone none of my followers are breaking
ATMs this is not what my followers do
and if they do then I immediately
descend them because they're not my
followers because this is nothing that I
preach but on campus the idea that you
have to uncritically accept Authority is
obviously true right this is why you
have speech codes and conduct codes and
every other kind of code it's why you
have kangaroo courts where due process
of law is not necessary kangaroo courts
ranging from political agitprop courts
where if you say something that offends
somebody get dragged in front of a court
for some sort of punishment - even some
of the title 9 courts you see people
like Laura Kipnis and Northwestern
University who's on the Left being
dragged in front of a title nine court
for daring to talk in politically
incorrect terms about sexual harassment
a third element is authoritarian
aggression a tendency to condemn anyone
who violates these conventional norms
and the idea that a person who has bad
manners and
that's inbreeding can hardly expect to
get along with decent people this is
probably the most common element you see
on campus this idea that all people who
disagree with the prevailing leftist
superstructure of thought they must be
cast out of decent society these people
are not you can't even talk with them
they shouldn't be invited to the cool
kid parties
you shouldn't have discussions with them
they are just bad people because they
disagree with you and we know that if
you accept the authority of the other
idea then disagreeing with that idea
makes you outside the bounds of
conventional society I mean it's the
equivalent of walking into a dinner
party and pooping on the floor if you go
in there and you just break all of the
rules then you're not welcome in polite
society and this is how conservatives
are treated on college campuses this is
the cheap method of converting
conservatives into being people in love
because if you want to go to the cool
kid parties if you want to be able to
associate with your fellow students if
you want to be seen as a decent person
and not as a bad person then you have to
accept this Authority and if you don't
then we will use these methods of social
ostracism in order to convince you not
that we're right but that you are evil
the fourth element is inferences
interception which is rejection of
weakness or sentimentality so you see
this a lot in sort of fascist countries
the idea that the businessman and
manufacturer are much more important to
society than the artist and the
professor so you see this there Hitler
is very much associated with this you
see this also actually in the Soviet
Union the idea that art is secondary to
work this is one of the elements that
Adorno I thought was key to
authoritarianism but what he missed was
the underlying thought structure for why
that is the reason that so many fascist
regimes don't like the artist and the
poet is because they're the dissenters
it's because the artist and the poet are
the people who look at the world in a
different and a dude in a new way
artists and poets are people who make a
life out of suggesting that there's
another way of looking at things and
that's why authoritarianism scans accept
them the authority authoritarianism
happy to sponsor art that agrees with
the regime I mean this is why famous
conductor Wilhelm furtwängler was was a
fan of the Nazis at least for a time and
the idea was that they were helping him
out I mean they sponsored Opera in
Germany they sponsored art in Germany
they sponsored particular types of art
the soviet union's did the same so
wasn't all artists who were thought to
be wrong it was the artists who didn't
agree with the regime so again this
comes down to compliance with the regime
this one this fifth
is one that I think is particularly
important on campus this is the
superstition in stereo teri oddity the
belief in mystical determinants of
action rigid categorical thinking this
idea that like someday it will shown it
will be shown that astrology can explain
a lot of things so superstition
dominates on campus because again when
to accept Authority you also have to
accept the superstition that comes with
this authority so this is why it is
taught in superstitiously rigid ways on
college campuses that you must never ask
questions that are politically incorrect
superstitions like the idea that men can
become women and women can become men
right there's no biological foundation
to this idea there's biological
foundations the idea of people who are
intersex there's biological foundations
the idea of people who have gender
dysphoria there's no biological
foundations the idea that a man who
believes he's a woman is actually a
woman there's no biological sex based
foundation for this it doesn't exist
because it's not true okay but this is
accepted as a as a fact of life it's a
stereo it is a superstition that we all
must accept just like walking under a
ladder is gonna bring you bad luck man
and men is not man the woman is not a
woman all of this is just gender assist
normative nonsense right you see this
with regard to questions about about
science in in global warming now I
happen to believe that the world is
warming but I think there are serious
questions to be asked about the
sensitivity of the climate to carbon
emissions these questions are being
asked by a wide variety of science
scientists right now there are questions
to be asked about the best method for
tamping that down where the market is
the best method but if you ask any of
these questions then you are guilty of
violating the superstition you violated
the religion I mean this is treated as
religious tradition on the Left these
elements superstitious religious
traditions okay as a religious person I
know what a religion looks like okay
this is what a religion looks like this
idea that if you violate the tenets of
the priesthood then you must be cast out
into the outer darkness okay sixth
element power and toughness
preoccupation with dominance over others
there's no question that this exists on
college campuses auntie feh is the most
obvious example of this the reason that
it was important for folks like me to go
to Berkeley is because the antifa had
basically suggested that we have locked
at with this is our campus right this
when you hear chants like whose campus
our campus right well it's not just your
campus in fact my tax dollars are
sponsoring you morons to go to this
campus but power and toughness
are they are the sort of underlying
notion for a lot of folks on the campus
left that we dominate this campus that
we are the powers on this campus and we
must not be challenged for all the talk
about pacifism the least pacifistic
people on campus are the ones who are
out there beating up supporters of mine
who want to come to my speeches the
seventh element that backs off fort
arianism the authoritarian personalities
destructiveness and cynicism and
generalized feeling of hostility and
anger yes this exists on the left in
fact the entire basis for intersectional
theory lies in this destructiveness and
this destructiveness and cynicism that's
intersectionality in the nutshell
intersectionality is the theory that we
can basically decide how valuable your
view is based on the group to which you
belong because the group to which you
belong has certain grievances against
the entire structure of America and
those grievances have to be taken
seriously we have to be angry doesn't
matter if you can show that you were
victimized or not all that matters is
that you can say the system victimized
your group at the system victim and we
can create a scale and we can create a
scale of victimhood and this is what
intersectionality does it basically says
that gay people are about black people
who are above Hispanic people who are
above women who are above Native
Americans who are above Jews who are
above Asians who are above white people
white males particularly these straight
white males so if you're at the very
bottom of that intersectionality grid
then your opinion is is of meaningless
value because you have no reason to be
angry but you do have a reason to be
angry if you're a member of one of these
other groups this generalized feeling of
anger and hostility it doesn't have to
be justified by statistics it doesn't
have to be justified by evidence it
doesn't even have to be justified by
solid anecdotal evidence that can be
backed up by evidence if you're angry
there must be a reason for it and
therefore we all have to kowtow to your
anger subjectivity over rules
objectivity you don't have to prove
anything to anyone so long as you claim
some sort of credit in one of these
grooves this means that your views are
justified and therefore if your views
are justified everybody else's use are
unjustified based on the nature of the
group to which they belong a project
ibbity there's a tendency to project
inner emotions and impulses outward in
the for example most people don't
realize how much our lives are
controlled by plots hatched in secret
places there is no more conspiratorial
group in America today than left us on
college
they believe that the economy is rigged
against them right income inequality
means that Bill Gates is secretly
working with Warren Buffett to rig the
economy against them is the Bernie
Sanders perspective on economics that is
almost as ignorant as Bernie Sanders is
perspective on foreign policy and the
idea that income inequality is is a
ineffective capitalism when capitalism
has literally raised 50% of people on
planet earth from abject poverty is
inane
but this conspiratorial thinking that a
bunch of people got together to rig the
system on but on their own behalf is is
a hallmark of leftist thinking on
college campuses white privilege another
one of these hallmarks this idea that
there's a big conspiracy to keep you
down if you're a black person in America
there's a big conspiracy people like me
are getting together in our protocols of
the Elders of Zion meetings after
dominating on Fridays and we are
figuring out how to keep the black man
down this is soup rooted supremely
stupid and not only is it supremely
stupid it's supremely
counterproductive because it's teaching
individuals in the freest country in the
history of planet Earth that they can't
get ahead if they work hard but if they
abide by standards of decency and reason
but they still can't get ahead because
some conspiracy is out there to stop
them from succeeding that people like me
care about stopping people from
succeeding as opposed to getting the
government out of the way so that you
can succeed on your own the sort of
conspiratorial thinking dominates the
idea that women are victimized by
American society in terms of pay that
out there there's this structure of men
who are just keeping women down in terms
of pay instead of looking at actual
statistical evidence that shows that in
the 50 major cities in the United States
women are actually on average paid more
than men when they get out of college
and zones have babies and then they have
the same amount of work experience and
are working the same number of hours all
of this is conspiratorial thinking by
the way I don't want to suggest that
this exists oh man laughs some of these
elements do exist on parts of the right
I'm happy to talk about that probably in
the Q&A but this conspiratorial thinking
this idea that the world is rigged
against you runs directly counter to the
free will based notions of the founding
fathers and the Constitution of the
United States finally when it's all said
was the ninth element of
authoritarianism was in over an over
focus on sex this this bizarre
preoccupation with sex the the
preoccupation with proper sexual conduct
now people like door no like to put this
in the litany because obviously Theodor
Adorno was a Marxist and he believed in
the breakdown of the family structure
and he thought that the rigged
patriarchy of marriage was was bad it
was binding people in but if you look at
America today the people who tend to be
a lot more obsessed with sex or not the
people on the right they're not people
like me I'm a libertarian I really don't
care I mean do what you want in the
privacy of your own home as long as I
don't have to pay for it it doesn't
bother me one iota and my religious
perspective on that here's that here's
the nice thing about my religious
perspective on your sexual behavior it's
a free country
you can think I'm an idiot you can
ignore me but I don't feel the
government has any role whatsoever in
regulating what you do behind closed
doors but the left seems to have this
bizarre preoccupation with everything
sexual this bizarre preoccupation with
what I think about your sex life that I
have to be forced to agree with your sex
life I have to be forced as a religious
person to bake that cake I have to be
forced as a religious person to allow my
church or my synagogue to give the okay
to behavior that I don't find
appropriate if there's one group in
America that is preoccupied with
foisting certain sexual standards on
everyone else
it is certainly left in that is
certainly Tron campus it places like the
UC system where they were they're
promulgating no means no policies which
essentially say that you have to have
like a 50-point checklist every time you
want to have sex okay I am as prudish as
anyone on earth I was known for many
years as the virgin bed and this is
legitimately
this was legitimately made legitimately
my nickname online for most of my early
career until I got married and lost my
virginity my wife okay the fact is that
when it comes to the this idea that
every that sex is going to be done with
it with a lawyer on the side of the room
taking notes this is not how sex is done
folks and that which is why by the way I
think it's sex should be done in the in
the context of marriage it's why I'm a
big proponent of marriage because it's
one of the things that it is done and at
that point within the bounds of a
contract actually and you don't need a
lawyer that's one of the nice things all
of this all of these elements add up to
a field that is right for a crewman when
it comes to shutting down those who
disagree because all of these elements
exist on the campus left again Adorno
wanted to restrict this to the right
because he was a partisan but if you
don't restrict it to the right if you
actually broaden these elements to
encompass all of politics you see a lot
of these authoritarianism the left and
intolerance is the ultimate outcome
dissent has to be silenced people like
me
run through hoops in order to speak and
the administration will try to determine
whether I'm guilty of hate crimes for
for speaking what I think is the truth
for speaking in reasonable terms hey I
asked earlier how many of the people on
the left we're here and there are some
people who are here I haven't seen any
of them running out of the room with
their hair on fire or committing suicide
in the room because of what I'm saying
it seems like they can all get along
just fine it seems like they're all
mentally strong enough at one of the
best colleges in America that they can
handle a little bit of disagreement
which is good because that's how the
country is supposed to work but that
unfortunately does not tend to be the
rising tide on the left instead the
ideas to even lend credence to people
like me a mainstream conservative to
even lend credence to people like me by
showing up would be to grant credibility
to a perspective that must be quashed at
the earliest opportunity the founding
fathers thought differently from all of
us the founding fathers were right they
thought in terms of individualism okay
they thought they thought that you had a
right to speak freely not because all
opinions are equal they weren't moral
relativists they didn't think that all
opinions were correct they didn't think
at all perspectives were elected were
extant think any of that but what the
Founding Fathers did believe is that we
were all individually made in the image
of God and that came along with certain
inalienable rights and one of those
inalienable rights was the right to
exercise our free will and our reason in
coming up with arguments and to express
those arguments in order to convince
others this is something that the
founders deeply believed is what the
First Amendment is all about and this is
what undergirded all of the ideas of the
free government and they were certain by
the way that if left to our own devices
that social institutions properly
supported by the community could fill a
gap left by a non tyrannical government
right in order to force people to be
virtuous folks like Aristotle talked
about having an overbearing government
that would basically cause virtue and
the founding fathers disagreed with that
they said well that ignores the fact
that virtue has to be an exercise of
free will that's why we need social
institutions to fill those gaps but we
need a government that doesn't impede
people in pursuing their own free will
okay that is the best way an American
conservatism is not authoritarian
American conservatism is not Hitlerian
American conservatism is not Marxist
it's not authoritarian leftism
American conservatism is about
individualism it's the opposite of the
American left and the campus left that's
why our campuses require hundreds of
police officers every time I speak
I mean I don't know how much money this
campus is speaking just to have me here
I spoke here two years ago with no
security now when I con I have to have
literally dozens and dozens and dozens
of police officers showing up a taxpayer
expense which of course is why I pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
state and tax but the good news that pay
for myself but the the bad news is that
whenever the whenever the left
authoritarian mindset predominates on
campus it quashes as the debate so
that's why I'm so glad that I get to
speak to you here tonight it's why I'm
glad that the university at least did
its job and allowing me to come and
speak again I wish that they had done
more to allow more people in the room
because I know that there were hundreds
of more people who wanted to show up in
here but I'm really grateful to all of
you for showing up and taking a night
off from partying and drinking to come
out and hear a different perspective
thanks so much and I'm excited to hear
the questions
[Applause]
so I think there are microphones at the
size of the rooms we're actually doing
two lines on this side of the room so
everyone that has a question please file
over here into two lines and we have
orange tape to mark up where you need to
stop and as always I do have one rule
which I forgot to mention to the VRS
widget by the way I'm really happy that
the Bruno publicans have grown to such a
side the campus conservatives run in
such a size when I was like me and three
other people but but if you if you
disagree with me if you're on the west
raise your hand get to go to the front
of the line that's the wrong thank you
guys at the sake of time I'm gonna limit
your question to 30 seconds and I'm
gonna hold out on the microphone through
the entirety of you asking your question
to make sure and when you ask your
question please don't walk in front of
the stage walk back to your seat did the
way you came
hello there so I was mainly doing some
research with one of my friends who is
studying urban planning and I'm not sure
to what extent is this question have to
directly pertain to the idea of my sex
life which is none of your business
oh okay so it's awesome by the way oh
[Applause]
all right so what I was thinking about
as I was doing research about like
homeless people who live in Sacramento
and sort of like addressing the issues
of I guess there are a lot of people who
speak in advocacy groups that are trying
to basically prevent ordinances from
moving these people out of these
communities they're living sort of like
in homeless encampments you homeless
encampments and stuff so I was just
wondering what do you believe is the
conservative approach towards perhaps
producing housing or you know programs
that get these sort of people off the
streets and like okay so first of all I
don't believe that the vast majority of
people who are homeless are homeless
because of a lack of affordable housing
there there are homeless shelters that
people can go to there are also places
in the United States that are not Los
Angeles where the rent is not nearly as
expensive as it is in places like Los
Angeles and building government
sponsored housing has been a failure in
carrying homelessness virtually
everywhere that it's been tried because
there a lot of people who don't want to
abide by the rules of particular
homeless in homeless housing that when
they practice in Seattle for example
then one of two things is happening that
have set standards and say no drugs no
alcohol and then a lot of people don't
want to be there or they don't set those
standards in the place hits wrecked so
this is been a serious problem there
places like Utah believe that have tried
certain government funded programs it
seems to be a little bit more successful
the the chief problem as I view it with
regard to homelessness is that there has
been in a tremendous underfunding
particularly of a mental illness
outreach programs a huge number of
people who are a huge number of people
who are on the streets are mentally ill
and have serious mental illness and that
is largely due to the federalization of
the mental illness industry since the
1960s and it needs to be returned to the
local level and local communities need
to take responsibility for that problem
I don't believe that people have a right
to sleep on the streets I don't believe
that people have a right to clog the
public thoroughfares I don't believe
that people have the right to poop in
public I don't believe any of these
things and so it is the in order to keep
a safe community for people we ought to
take care of people who legitimately
can't take care of themselves but by the
same token
you don't get to live on the street just
because you say you want to live on the
street thanks heaven how's it going so I
guess my question is pretty quick but
what is an issue for you that you've
changed your position on most frequently
or if you can't if nothing comes to mind
what's a position you've changed most
recently okay so the choose positions
where I've changed my position that I
can recall
well three so the three positions that I
can recall are I used to be much more
stringent with regard to a legalization
of marijuana
I no longer care about that issue mainly
because I see that the government's not
said everything so I think there is a
solid case to be made that you know with
regard to the opioid epidemic the
government has a role in preventing
people from obtaining substances to
which they're addicted and can't get off
but marijuana doesn't seem to me to
fulfill all those criteria I think that
it damages teenage brains I think that
you're stupid if you use it regularly
and you should stop I think you're
wasting your life but I think that
people have right to be stupid in ways
their lives as they want to it's a free
country as far I think that the second
issue is with regard to same-sex
marriage I'm still anti-same-sex
marriage from a social point of view I
think that heterosexual marriage is the
only relationship that actually has
positive value that is measurable to
society and there may be advantages to
civil unions over non civil unions but
that's not marriage in the traditional
sense which is about production rearing
of children I've changed my position not
with regard to that but with regard to
the government so I used to believe that
the government had a role in in
regulating marriage I no longer believe
that again because it comes back to my
original premise that the government
sucks at everything and the government's
attempts to sponsor traditional marriage
have not only failed it backfired
because now you're seeing same-sex
marriage enshrined alongside traditional
marriage at the government level which
is going to end with crackdowns on
religious institutions that refuse to
abide by the government's definition of
marriage and that scares me and I don't
like it and so I'm libertarian on this
issue and I think the government should
get completely out of the business of
marriage and it should just be a
contractual relationship between two
people you know that is what it is in
the Jewish community right I have my
ketubah which is my contract my marriage
contract with my wife and that's the
only one that mattered to me when I got
our state marriage contract it meant
nothing to me we got it a couple months
before we were Jewishly married the
Jewish marriage one meant everything to
make us a minute I could finally have
sex with her so that's the
so so that is the so that's another area
I've also changed my position when
you're 19 you tend to be much more
radical with regard to your foreign
policy your belief in foreign policy
utopianism I'm far less utopian on
foreign policy than I used to be in
terms of issues that can be quote
unquote solved and so I used to advocate
measures with regard to the israeli-arab
conflict and I no longer advocate and
haven't advocated for years and have
openly denounced I think that's an
intractable conflict that is basically
only going to be a continuing and
continuing intractability with defense
on the side of the Israelis until the
end of time is my basic perspective on
that but that is a shift from earlier
positions I had advocated which I now
think are moral first of all this one
pleasure to be here with you mr. Shapiro
my question is will you ever bury the
hatchet with my lowly innopolis and well
can we expect maybe a debate between you
and him or even maybe something better
like you two collaborating on common
issues and speaking to a bunch of people
like right now
no first of all I'm glad to see or White
Sox fans oh my but as far as the the
Milo issue I have no time for someone
who flirts with the only neo-nazis of
the alright I have no time for somebody
who sends tweets to me of black children
on the day that my child is born to
demonstrate that I'm a I have no
time for somebody who holds a book party
with with midgets wearing my nametag and
I mean I guess it's somewhat funny and
and bibs that say it's my bris I can cry
if I want to because that's actually
just pure anti-semitic trope I think now
I've been saying for a long time that
Milo does not represent conservatism and
yeah by the way I have note I have no
tolerance for somebody who implies that
it's good for children there when they
are raped by adults so that there's that
too so I have many criticisms of Milo
and I don't see him being as being
valuable member of any movement to which
I belong and and I have it for well over
a year
final note on that sorry before I finish
ant I left does not mean conservative
okay Milo is anti left that does not
mean you're conservative how's it going
how's it going Ben so you talked about
how you came here two years ago and
spoke and how there wasn't really any
kind of big protest going on trying to
stop you like you've seen happen at
Berkeley and even here the 15 people you
mentioned were outside and so I was
wondering do you think that the big
political climate change were there not
like a lot of leftists haven't let
conservative speakers come on campus and
such do you think it has more to do with
the Obama administration or the Trump
administration I think it has more to do
with Obama the reason I can say that
with certainty is because the first
major protest against me was in February
2016 before trumpet even won the
nomination so that was a Cal State Los
Angeles and there was basically a near
riot there they had helicopters flying
and I was I had to be rushed off campus
by motorcycle cops and felt like I felt
like a Latin American dictator
attempting to escape a revolution it was
it was really those quite bizarre but
the the the reason that I think that it
rose is because the the Obama
administration did a wonderful job of
ginning up their base to believe that if
your feelings were hurt it was okay to
act out in violence and that was not
restricted to campus issues like a
University of Missouri it was also
taking place in places like Ferguson and
places like Baltimore this idea that if
you have grievances that those
grievances can be acted out in a violent
way and we may not agree to violence but
you sort of get it I think the dad had
some pretty significant effects on how
people thought and what people thought
they could get away with I think that
you know obviously the heightened
political climate has certainly
exacerbated a lot of that I think that
you know Trump a it's not his fault per
se there are a lot of things I think
from our Trump's fault I don't think
this is one of them but it's but the
political climate has not made things
easier for sure
hey Ben
a couple years ago you you debated the
n-double-a-cp correct yes well know them
but they're kind of sorry so when you
get a debate
Tariq Nasheed on racism I mean when when
Sarika nasheed can can gather a crowd
larger than seven it's so III I don't
find him to be honestly I don't find
Tariq Nasheed from what I've seen online
to be a particularly reasonable advocate
of his point of view I think there are
other people who I be interested more in
debating I think yeah a really
fascinating debate would be with
somebody like Tana he's he coats for
example I think that would be a really
interesting to makes I think I really
disagree with Tana he see coats I think
that he he sees things through a false
prism but I think that he's a more
intelligent spokesperson for that point
of view than Tariq who seems to be more
of a provocateur to me but I consider it
I mean if if there was some group that
wanted sponsor something like that I'd
consider it at least so how would you
define the alt-right and what kind of
object objective view could you say it's
a minority of the conservative movement
okay so on objective view that it's a
minority of the concern okay so let me
first start the definition and then and
then the statistics so the definition of
the alright there is the colloquial
definition would be all right then
there's the specific definition the
specific definition is the alt-right was
started by people like Jared Taylor and
Richard Spencer Jared Taylor was the
creator of I believe American
Renaissance and Richard Spencer was the
creator of alternative right and the
idea behind alternative right is that
the mainstream right refused to
acknowledge specific differences in
races that had ramifications for
politics is the basic idea that black
people were not as intelligent and we're
more crime ridden this is the basic idea
of the alright and that culture is
inseparable from races Western
civilization was a creation of white
people and that other people from
different races cannot assimilate into
this because there are racial barriers
to assimilation I think all of this is
not just stupid I think it's evil and so
you know that that is the that's the
perspective of the alright it's the core
perspective so what happened is that
this was always considered very fringe
movement right this is like five people
it's like it really I mean it's a very
very smuggling these are the sort of
people who had marched in
Charlottesville
the crowd in Charlotte feels like a
thousand people there maybe 10,000
hardcore members of the alt-right across
the country I know this because I was
the number one target of the alright in
2016 on Twitter I received 7400
anti-semitic tweets from the alt-right
over the course of about seven months
according to the anti-defamation league
I was the number one recipient of
anti-semitic tweets on Twitter side a
great year last year was awesome and but
it only came from at 1100 accounts it
was not coming from a huge variety of
people who really believe this stuff
then the alt rights definition was
broadened so as the right made what I
think is a truly tragic and desperate
move from conservatism into just being
anti left the alt-right started to rise
in esteem because these were people who
were truly everything like control and
they like to make memes and so what they
did is they suckered people into
believing that if you weren't an
establishment conservative and you liked
memes you liked Tyrande memes if you
thought that if you thought that memes
were funny or if you liked to troll
people on Twitter that this meant that
you remember of the alt-right so they
sort of hid the ball a little bit they
they didn't leave with the white
supremacism but they did instead as they
said we're not establishment we hate the
establishment the establishment is
incompetent what have they ever done for
you were people who are fighting for a
new tomorrow and join us and we hate the
left this much and they've gotten say
provocative things and the left and
fight then and then people would say oh
well I hate the left too so I guess I'm
all right
I don't like Mitch McConnell also so I
guess I'm not right I know that this was
the perspective of a lot of people
because in the middle of this Hewett
who's a friend of mine and a talk show
host that I respect Hugh and one point
called me a member of the alright while
I was being targeted by the alright
that's because he thought that I was
anti mitch mcconnell's i must be alright
and i had to explain to him that's not
what the alt-right is so a lot of people
were sort of suckered into believing
they were members of the alright if they
don't like jeb bush for president or if
they like Donald Trump for president if
they like anyone who's
anti-establishment
sure nonsense sure nonsense right you
can I was for Ted Cruz for president I
was certainly not for Jeb Bush for
president and and that did not make me a
member of the alright so there was this
widespread perception that the core all
right was was actually bigger than it
was because they deliberately hit the
ball one of the people who did this was
Milo Milo went on places like MSNBC and
he said that it's just a trolley group
of jolly people who had nothing to do
with white supremacism they just
believed in cultural superiority not
racial superiority absolutely false milo
knew better he was corresponding with
the all right at the time and he wrote
an entire piece about it so
all of that said what that led the media
to do was then exacerbate the influence
would be all right because now they had
a convenient whipping boy so now what
they could say is everybody on the right
is actually alright right everyone who
opposed jeff bush they like Donald Trump
that means they're all right and that
means that they like Richard Spencer
well that's a gap right just because you
like Trump doesn't mean that you like
Richard Spencer so so I think that
there's a little bit obfuscation by the
media I think there's some ignorance in
the media as to what all these groups
mean and the alt-right is remains a very
small group so small but there were
people on the so-called all like who
were disassociating from the all right
during the Charlottesville rallies so
it's a very very small group of people
who the media keep giving attention to
because they hope that we're all like
Richard Spencer and not like people who
hate Richard Spencer like me hello Ben
my name is Steven and I I really want to
say that you deserve all this popular
you're getting because of the moral
objectivism and truth that you preach
and I really think it's refreshing you
know thank you every minute
so my question is I am Coptic Christian
and although I wasn't born in Egypt or
I'd never faced any of the persecution
that's currently going on there I'm
still deeply rooted to my culture and
this hatred of culture appropriation
that I'm seeing is an anomaly to me and
I really want to know is why does the
left why is the left so repulsed at the
idea of celebrating culture so I think
that the left is is focusing in on
cultural appropriation because again
this goes back to the idea that we can
only identify as members of groups right
that we can't identifies individuals who
can actually supersede our genetics or
our environment or the group to which we
are born and so what the left likes to
do is because they here's the short
story of intersectionality it began a
long time ago
the beginnings of intersectionality
basically like Marxist theory so Marx
believed that there would be class war
that allowed the underclass to destroy
the system that never happened because
it turns out capitalism makes everyone
wealthier so instead the Marxist left
decided that they were going to use
various racial groups to do this in the
1960s there's a real movement to
separate various groups women were
victimized by the system blacks were
victimized by the system and there's
truth to some of this right in the 1960s
it's not true now but the idea was that
all of these groups were victimized by
the system you bind them all together
and then they will
go fight against the man and so group
identity became paramount your identity
as a member of the group was the key
thing so Clarence Thomas is not really
black because he doesn't act like a
quorum quote real black person because
he's conservative right and you see the
the you know there's even talk that
people like me are not really Jewish
because I'm because I'm on the right eye
which of course is absurd especially
considering that 70% of Orthodox Jews
are on the right so what the idea here
is that if you were to accept cultural
appropriation if you were to accept that
we're individuals who can like certain
things from different cultures then
those artificial barriers follow
immediately right if we can all take
from what we like from each other's
cultures then that means as individuals
we are not bound within these false
confines that the left is created for us
and so they have to reestablish the
segregation these segregation notions
that we cannot appropriate anything from
this culture this culture that if
something is good for that culture it
must be specific to that culture
all that does is it condemns people to a
life of living within certain boundaries
that may or may not be good because
certain things from other cultures are
fantastic and better than what's in your
culture a cultural appropriation is the
story of Western civilization it's it's
the story it really is I mean it's the
story of Western civilization growing
and expanding and taking into account
two other ideas that are that are better
over time I think that's why Western
civilization is is so dominant is
because of things like cultural
appropriation
hey Ben thank you so much for coming out
my name is Alexander and I'm a big fan
so I was born in Toronto and I lived
there for one year but I've lived in
California for the past ten years and I
have a dream of becoming a United States
Senator when I grow up but one thing I
can't do is become president United
States because I'm not a natural-born
citizen and this kind of became a bit of
an issue with Ted Cruz in the last
election cycle so what my question
really is is what I don't understand is
if I'm someone who's lived in this
country practically my whole life worked
here raised a family here paid taxes
here and potentially served in public
office here I can't become president the
United States even Henry Kissinger was
Secretary of State even though he was
born in Germany you can do anything else
run for Senate governor congressman
we're you know everything else but I
can't be present the United States so my
question is do you think I should be
able to become president even though I'm
not a natural-born citizen and if so do
you think that it will ever be the case
that that's true one day so I do think
the dadoes provision of the Constitution
that probably will be changed at some
point that the original rationale for
that provision of the Constitution was
because they wanted to make sure that
the people who are running for president
of the United States did not have
foreign allegiances and so the easiest
way to do that was make sure that
everybody was actually born in the
United States at the time is the easiest
way to sort of lead people out in an era
when half the people were actually born
and you know Britain or France or other
places abroad I think that as we as
we've moved on as a society and as
they're immigrants who come to the
country who are more representative of
American values than some people who are
born here I've really I'm not to be
honest with you I'm not a huge fan of
this provision of the Constitution
lasting because I don't think that it's
been a very good parchment barrier
against people with ideas that are on
American becoming president so as I
think that the idea that they being born
in America is the sort of guarantor of
allegiance to the country or to the
country's ideals I don't think that's
true
I think that you know we should we
should do a better job of vetting our
candidates so that they have allegiance
to the ideals yeah I know there are a
lot of conservatives who disagree with
this and just sort of like the idea
because it's there I'm not one of these
I'm not wedded to it particularly so if
you're a fan of mine I would be much
happier with you as pres
than any of the last several alright hey
Ben my name is Jacob I know you were
very religious Orthodox Jew
I'm as well a Coptic Christian and I
feel like the aspect of the left is
mostly godless their principles so I
wanted to know how can we merge politics
and God back into society because I feel
recently it's been God's over the years
been really left out I think that's why
a lot of the liberal or not liberal left
positions I've been taking place so I
agree with you that the increasing
secularism of the United States is the
single best indicator for the rise of
the political left in the United States
I make virtually all of my arguments not
on the basis of religion but on the
basis of secular arguments because I
think that it's conversation we can have
if I cite the commissure if I say the
Torah then somebody who doesn't believe
that is not going to agree with me just
because we have different points of
authority that said a society that
rejects God rejects the fundamental
premise of an objective moral standard
to which we should all be held
accountable and this is a serious
problem it also by the way it rejects
and the at least the logical consequence
of rejecting the notion of a vey God who
created us and instilled us with
freewill the logical consequence of that
notion is that we are basically
meaningless balls of meat wandering
through the universe and that this
concept comes complete with no form of
morality to which we can be held and
comes complete with no sense of
responsibility to which we should be
held because balls of meat don't have
responsibilities they are just firing
synapses in response to their
environment a secular materialism the
sort of atheistic scientific materialism
actually undermines many of the cause of
the left claims to stand for like I
don't understand where the left a
secular atheist I don't understand where
a secular atheist gets off explaining
about human rights where do those come
from on what basis there are no rights
construct has to come from somebody's
moral mind okay and if you are just
legitimately an outcome of your DNA and
whatever environment is operating on you
don't even have free will then your
morality is just an outcome of that - so
how is that moral how is that more moral
than than a snake biting a dog it isn't
and so the idea of a strict secular
humanism
now is is self-contradictory actually if
you like this topic I'm writing an
entire book on it right now
so yeah but the idea that the idea of
reason reason does not exist from a
scientific materialist perspective it
doesn't it's just different synapses
firing in your brain the idea of mind
itself doesn't really exist for a
scientific materialist perspective
because how do you identify mind right
what how do you identify an idea where
does the idea reside why is one idea
more important than another idea all of
the fundamental premises that the left
has built in its entire morality on our
built ungodly concepts and now they've
rejected God ready even the idea of
freewill doesn't exist in secular
materialism right sam Harris who I'm
gonna be debating on some of this stuff
actually in about three weeks I like Sam
in a lot of topics and I hope that we
have a good conversation on this sam is
honest enough in his book about freewill
to basically see if there is none to
which I ask okay so why are we bothering
with the debate right because if we were
if we're not actually going to be if
we're not actually gonna be convincing
somebody or if the convincing was
predestined from the beginning of time
then I guess that that's a purpose sort
of but not really so I agree with you
and increasingly secular society has
ripped out the moorings upon which it is
based
and eventually secular humanism is going
to fall into full-scale collectivism in
which the majority the majority drive
dominates and that's a dangerous thing
hey Ben thanks for coming to hear you
speak in person
big fan listen to your podcast a lot
thank you
there was one question that you answered
a little bit a little while ago it's a
little bit out of your wheelhouse but
just wanted to bring it back up because
I thought that your answer was a little
bit invalid so basically you're asked
about the morality of killing animals
for food and you basically justified it
by saying that killing animals is
immoral because I think that human
beings have a right to survive and think
that we need animal protein to survive
it as a general matter I definitely
agree that like human beings have a
right to survive like for sure it's been
pretty thoroughly debunked that humans
require animal protein to to thrive the
Academy of Nutrition and Dietetics which
is the largest organization of
nutritional experts in the world has
basically said that basically vegan diet
is nutritionally adequate at all stages
of life and protein deficiencies are
basically non-existent as long as you're
eating enough calories and there's also
many vegan athletes that are very
successful so I didn't think that that
justification that you made was valid so
I was just wondering if you had happy to
look at the studies and determine
whether I think you're right or not I
mean like again I think they just I'm
not assuming was there anything else
that I mean I do think that there is a
fundamental distinction between animal
life and human life that actually needs
to be upheld and I don't think that we
should go randomly killing animals or
mistreating animals but I think that the
idea that a human being is the same as
an animal is is and I know you're not
saying that I'm but I'm saying that some
of that undergirds some elements of sort
of the vegan movement which is the human
beings and animals are of equal value
and therefore you can't kill an animal
for food so I if the argument is that
you don't have a need base for food then
maybe that's true and if that's the case
then I would actually you know I've said
before I think that there are some
pretty good arguments for vegetarianism
or veganism yeah this is the fact that
we have like readily available
alternatives that right so that so that
that I think is the best argument for
veganism I think the worst argument for
veganism is sort of the PETA argument
you know that the sort of the Holocaust
on your plate nonsense but it's it but I
but I do
I do again I think that if we're
needlessly killing animals then then you
know I would consider that would
consider moving away from that although
I really miss hamburger City hey so I
had a question tonight I saw this sort
of like nine-point speech it about left
being fastest and the campus less
specific yeah and so I felt there was a
lot of sort of selective referencing
there which I think obviously makes
sense that's you know the argument that
you're making one that I thought sort of
really stood out objectively that was
sort of wrong was the idea that the left
was more like sort of Pro into courts
conspiracy theories not sort of idea you
know I did say there's some other right
to are to so now we get stopped exactly
so you know what I think of is when you
look at like sort of like you know like
the statistics like you measured like
you know Donald Trump supporters who
believe Barack Obama was a Muslim
believe that global warming isn't real
believe that the earth is you know eight
thousand years old belief that we didn't
evolve believe those sorts of things
it's like demonstrably higher on the
right than it is on the left in terms of
like very clearly measurable it depends
on the conspiracy theory right so if you
go back to the Bush administration then
left beliefs about conspiracies
surrounding 9/11 or about WMDs in Iraq
and all this kind of stuff very high so
it really does depend on the conspiracy
theory and as I said I think there's
conspiratorial thinking on both sides I
don't think that's unique to to the left
what I was saying is that on the campus
it's more prevalent on the left than it
is on the right with regard to big
elements of American society so I think
you that you're right there there number
of you're right the polls say that a lot
of Republicans say that Obama is
actually a Muslim and was born in Kenya
and that's a silly conspiracy theory you
know yeah exactly the South Ridge pizza
gate nonsense you know that crap is
prevalent on the right conspiracy
theories unfortunately I think
conspiracy theories have actually become
a way of life because I don't think that
how do i phrase this I think a lot of
the right is not actually conservative
and the reason that I say that is
because I think a lot of the right has
become anti left and what that means is
that if you are mostly anti something
you tend to attribute conspiratorial
thinking to that group of people so I
think that you know maybe I'm falling
for the no true Scotsman fallacy here a
little bit by saying that we
conservatives don't tend to buy into
conspiratorial thinking but I think that
we live in an era unfortunately when
politics is motivated by anger and
unjustified anger on all sides as being
justified by politicians and so a lot of
people have a lot of different
conspiracy theories but let's put this
way it's not absent on the campus left
it's very prevalent on the campus left
yeah well yeah so I guess you know one
thing I'm like you know the no true
conservatives believe that I could say
the same thing you know no true
Democrats believe that 9/11 was done by
you know Bush administration so that's
how many Democrats believe that Bush
lied people died I think right there's
pretty like you can watch sort of like
him saying something in something else
but you can't you cannot watch him
saying that there are WMDs in Iraq and
attribute that's a deliberate lie unless
you are also willing to tribute that
deliberate line to your own party
everyone on the Left made the same
contention including Bill Clinton and
Hillary Clinton and Chuck Schumer
announced evil they all made the same
contention no one says that they were
lying they only say the bush was lying
because that's politically convenient
and they think there was a conspiracy
here here's a more common one that's
easier for you okay how many people on
the Left believed it was war for oil
that's supremely common on the Left if
it was war for oil why didn't we get any
oil so I mean is what I'm saying like I
think the conspiracy theories have
become as if politics has become more
partisan and as we've looked at each
other as enemies rather than friends we
tend to attribute bad motivations to our
enemies
[Applause]
- my name is Louis I'm a huge fan
you're my conservative political mentor
I'm a daily wire subscriber and that's
thank you every day
my my question is as a conservative
Latino that at the conservative Latino
in a you know divisive world that seems
to be get going
literally black and white on every issue
how does conservatism the movement and
how does the conservative movement bring
about more Latinos to the conservative
costs so I mean I think that it really
is a matter of promulgating perspectives
that everyone can buy into so I spoke at
the California Republican convention
maybe four years ago now three four
years ago and in my keynote I actually
suggested that conservative should learn
Spanish specific not because I think
that Latinos who don't speak English
shouldn't learn English I think
everybody should learn English but I
also think that conservatism is message
is not restricted to one language and so
I've been diligently failing at
attempting to learn Spanish ever since
but but I think that one of the things
that I agree with you that there is an
entertainment aspect to some of
conservatism that says the more extreme
position you take and more popular you
will be I don't think that's right I
think that it's not about the extremism
of the position that you take I think
it's about the truth of the position
that you take and the strength of
conviction with which you say it so I
don't actually think that Donald Trump
won because he was the most conservative
candidate I think he won because he said
things in the clearest fashion they may
even be the wrong things in many cases I
believe but he said them in the clearest
fashion and he said them with the most
passion and I think that does make a
difference that's unfortunately how sort
of our lizard brain works is that we
respond to that so if you say the right
things with that same level of passion
and intensity that I think that people
hear it so you know with regard to
immigration I I've always taken the
position on immigration that I do not
have any objections to legal immigration
whatsoever so long as people are not on
welfare and the one to assimilate to
American values including founding
ideals you do that
come on in
and what I've always said with regard to
illegal immigrants is that the I mean we
live in Los Angeles so if you live in
Los Angeles you know and have worked
with the illegal immigrants what I've
always said with regard to illegal
immigrants is that it is a crime
obviously to jump the border but the
idea that everyone is jumping the border
to commit crime is obviously not true
the vast majority of people who are
jumping the border are drumming the
border to create a better life for their
family does that justify jumping the
border not from an American point of
view we still get to select who comes
into the United States we're still a
sovereign land and we get to decide who
comes in with that said the people who
are already here we should determine on
a case-by-case basis whether the United
States would be better with them in or
out and then we should either put them
at the back of the line we'll kick them
out right if you if you deserve to be
here we'll put you the back of the line
you get to wait just like everybody else
but if you if you don't deserve to be
here then we kick you out but we do it
on a case by case basis I think one of
the mistakes that people make is they're
always talking about people in terms of
class so you get this this debate all
the illegal immigrants should stay or
all illegal immigrants should go why how
about the ones we like today and the
ones we don't go that's the way we do
the rest of our immigration program and
I think that most people who are Latino
and citizens in the United States agree
with that I mean Latino people in the
United States on people who are coming
here with bad motives to come here no
matter where they're coming from either
so I think that that's it's a mistake
and how people talk about immigration
again thinking that the extremism of
their position can substitute for the
clarity and passion of their position
[Applause]
so first I'd like to thank you CPD and
everyone that organized this event
because I was a Mylo you know a year and
a half ago it was an absolute mess but
this was really smooth so so as a Jew
I've noticed a pretty concerning rise
and either the incidence or visibility
of anti-semitism over the last year two
years both in the bonafide sense like
you know the people in Charlottesville
in the daily stormer folks and all the
alright folks and in a much more casual
sense from many people on the campus
left
I like that cartoon of Berkeley a couple
weeks ago all the PDF stuff and and you
know the equation of Israel with Jews
and and anti-israel sentiment being
essentially anti-semitism yes which as
someone who has been a victim of
anti-semitism for both sides which one
are you more concerned about if either
and why much more concerned with the
anti-semitism of the left and not just
some of the right the reason I'm more
concerned with the anti-semitism on the
left is because I think it's closer to
the heart of left meaning that the the
anti-semites on the left people like
keith Ellison he was almost the head of
the DNC the the BDS movement has become
a hallmark of the campus left I mean
it's it's growing in strength on a lot
of campuses around the country and it's
being used as a rallying point it's
almost sort of an anti-western rallying
point by a lot of folks on the left
though the leftist perspective on Israel
is basically that Israel is bad because
Israel is prosperous and rich and it is
an outpost of Western civilization in a
non-western part of the world and
therefore it's colonialist that is
really an anti-western position I don't
think it's any coincidence that when you
see students tried to pass a divestment
petition they also tried to divest at
Berkeley from the United States which
would have been weird because then they
would have had to float about 100 feet
off the off the ground in order to fully
divest from the United States although
we have air rights I believe but in any
case the I'm more worried about that
because by statistics the movement
against the toward anti-israel position
toward a Pro Hamas position is much
stronger on the Left than it is on the
right
that said the growth of this kind of alt
right paleo conservative isolationism
anti-israel thing has really taken a lot
of people by surprise I do think it's
minority movement inside the
conservative movement I mean even a lot
of places that are
considered kind of alt-right friendly
like take the right part where I used to
work that's a very pro-israel
publication all right if you like it's
it's it's been I think horribly friendly
to to a lot of folks on the alright in a
disgusting way which is one of the
reasons I've been ripping on them for a
year and one of the reasons why I think
Milo is a terrible example for that site
but it's but Milo himself is not
anti-israel and neither is Breitbart and
so the the kind of growth of the
specific anti Jewish movement I think is
let's put this way I think it's more
specific on the alt right and I think
it's broader but deeper on the on the
Left I mean there's a select group of
people on the right who are really
openly anti-semitic and hate me and send
me death threats and send me memes about
my kids being gassed in gas chambers and
all this kind of crap but on the Left
what's closer to the heart of the
Democratic Party is an anti religious
bigotry and an anti-israel stance that
is much more dangerous to Jews in the
long run hi van so earlier tonight and
throughout a lot of the videos I've seen
you in you've made comments about how
the government is you know in competent
and capable generally bloated and being
a libertarian myself I couldn't agree
with you more so my question is which of
your positions that aren't direct you
know life liberty property natural
rights protections which of them do you
think the government should be stepping
in and why should we have this bloated
incompetent government stepping in on
this so we shouldn't have the bloated
incompetent government particularly on
the federal level stepping in I think
local government is a slightly different
issue because it's closer to home so I
have a sort of Montesquieu position on
the role of local government so I said
earlier about spending on mental health
facilities for example I specifically
mean local facilities I don't mean
federal facilities because local
government tends to be a little bit less
inefficient than federal like the bigger
the government gets in the more distance
it gets from the people who actually
elect it the less you know your
legislators the less you know the people
who are in charge of the money the more
inefficient the government tends to get
and more bloated it tends to get so I
think that there can be the idea and the
founders thought this too there could be
baseline kind of social safety nuts
whether they're these did exist in
colonial America but these existed at
the very very local level and
particularly at the communal level so my
ideal is that they don't exist from the
government at all right my ideals that
they exist in the religious community
this is why I think libertarians ought
to embrace the idea of
powerful social institutions like
churches that are actually there taking
care of poor people but if that's not
there then local communities are gonna
have to you know take care of their
certain groups of people who just can't
take care of themselves and if they fall
through the cracks then that's a
referendum on the local community so but
beyond that I don't think that the
federal government has a role in nearly
anything neither did the founders which
is why the Constitution is you know a
5700 word document that governs the gut
the entire the inherited federal
government hey Ben
I appreciate your podcast they get me
through le traffic yeah also I was a
member of the rural Republicans when I
was here so I'm glad to see they're
still doing these kind of things I was
like seven people when I was here I
actually emailed you to get another
ticket for my rabbi I'm a member of a
local Orthodox shul
he told me not to ask this because I
lose but I'm gonna do it anyways
it's about abortion okay and so okay so
here we go
Talmudic law states that an embryo is
not being fully viable until the
fortieth day and then Jewish warning
rights don't apply to an unborn child
the embryo is treated as an appendage
and Rashi which I know you know yeah and
Rambam right and Roger said that it's
it's considered right let's just say
it's still the 40th day that's not the
moment of creation because you know he
talked about bones and whatnot and
arteries forming also in the Exodus they
talked about how if two men get a fight
and a woman who's pregnant loses a child
he owes her the equivalent of an
appendage so my question to you is you
always talk about drawing a line in sand
where do you draw the line in the sand
moment of conception of creation
whatever so the line is 40 days
according to Rashi according to tal
mudak law why not draw the line of 40
why do you disagree with that
okay I just read that because basic
biology does not draw any distinction at
40 days so I think that you know muta
commentators who are writing in seven
DCE are less knowledgeable about basic
biology than we are now didn't have
ultrasounds they didn't know what was
going on in the womb there's some pretty
bad science and
helmet and to be frank there's there's a
pretty bad science in Rambam I think
Rambam would have been one of the first
people to actually suggest that modern
science ought to be taken at face value
that said even in the Talmud there's
there's no notion that you can abort at
will before 40 days so there's there
serious Halawa authorities not to get
too deep into Jewish law they're serious
philosophically many of them who have
talked about the the availability and
use of abortion before 40 days and the
vast majority decision from what I
understand is that it is essentially
forbidden except in exigent exigent
circumstances so they said it's
different standard with regard to visit
of life or is it not alive tell
musically but that doesn't actually
change the behavior of whether you're
allowed to obtain an abortion on you
know by choice before forty days one
follow-up assuming not the my the way I
don't find out for my opinions that is
one of these issues where I don't form
my opinions on secular law based on what
the Talmud says and in fact I think the
Talmud is actually logically incorrect
here let's just era C but not not
talking about the mother's life being in
danger because we put that one aside for
a second even like a Eliezer you'd
wallenberg one of the guys who was on
the Supreme extraordinarily liberal on
these issues so then you know he said
abortion is okay if you have taste
saxler and he destroy he's a real
outlier on these issues I mean I don't
really want abstruse like inside her
Jewish community debates but he's a he's
a he's a very he's a real outlier on
these issues waldenberg and it's taking
some very extreme stances on that on
things like transgenderism he's taking
extreme stances
he's much more socially left than the
vast majority of illogical authorities I
think it's probably a better idea hey
one last thing I just wanted to say this
isn't a Trump shirt it actually says
Seinfeld kostina and I can read it from
there I'm all for it just so you know
I bet biggest and the earliest fan from
overseas Hong Kong sorry for the bad
English started watching you for five
years back before you became legendary
but somehow I managed to luckily end up
in UCLA and have a chance to see you so
two disagreements with you I with you I
agree with you that a flat tax is sort
of moral but on a practical level I
don't think the middle class in the
lower lower sectors they're going to do
that well and they're gonna have a
significant financial burden we've
already addressed that and the second
question is you spend a lot of time on
the daily wire destroying the left and
dealing with the people calling you a
racist sexy figure homophobe whatever a
lot of things and then who put you in
danger as well I have done popular
opinion this is actually a very good
thing because like back in Hong Kong is
like 60% people talk about poverty or
today there's an earthquake in around
Iraq
I killed five hundred people I don't
think like many people know about this
so why do you have such as like I would
think like a disproportionate level of
outrage at issues that aren't that much
fun to daily wire okay well I mean I
think that you know the issues you know
with regard to the problems of the left
the reason I have disproportionate
outrage is for the same reason that you
know I'm outraged when someone steals a
car a mile away from me I'm more
outraged when someone breaks in my house
and starts robbing my fridge and the
left is is seeking to destroy a lot of
foundational values that I think the
country stands for and that's happening
in real time to the most powerful
country on Earth and as America goes so
goes the future the planet so that's why
I spend a disproportionate amount of
time fighting what I think are bad ideas
by the way on the left and also on
places like the all right as far as the
as far as the the first question which
remind me the first question the flat
tax is a flat tax question so I've said
that I think a flat tax is moral because
I think percentages are percentages but
as far as the efficacy of a flat tax one
of the suggestions has been that there
should be basically an elimination of
all tax for people below a certain level
and then a flat tax from there on up I
don't think that's completely wrong I
think that's I think that's acceptable
but again I think the idea of a
progressive tax where you make you pay
the more you make is both immoral and
also bad economics
they've been a huge fan and proud owner
of a tumbler then you know this is
Laurie but I work at a middle school
where I see teachers day in and day out
praise the left this way of thinking and
bash the conservative way of thinking
and I just want to know what you suggest
I would do to not necessarily promote
conservative but conservatism but to
just kind of keep a objective like
viewpoint with teaching the kids I mean
so I think that the question is sort of
two-part even though it really isn't the
the first part is how you do the
seconding fired right I mean that's that
really is the question one of the big
problems the public school level is that
it in California you have to be a member
of the teachers union to teach in a
public school and that's a disaster
because the teachers unions are really
discriminatory against people on the
right and they obviously take all your
money and they spend on leftist
politicians like Jerry Brown and it's an
serious problem yeah that's a question
you're gonna have to decide for yourself
how far you can you go without getting
fired as far as what you can say to the
kids I think that it's perfectly fine to
say here's an argument I heard one of
your other teachers making today it's a
valid argument
let me explain where I think it's
mistaken and if the other teacher is a
problem with that then let them talk
with you about it in front of the class
like this idea that you get a free feel
to say whatever you want in a classroom
without ever being contradicted I think
is incredibly stupid and I think it's
damaging to the kids because especially
it honestly I think that it one of the
reasons that the left is is actually
vulnerable on campus even though they
seem invulnerable on campus and this is
true in high schools and junior High's
as well they never hear a good position
on the rights when they finally hear a
good position on the right a lot of them
are convinced because they've never
actually had to deal with those ideas
before if they did deals with these
ideas nationally debate for themselves
whether they're true or not they get a
better perspective on where maybe they
actually stand so I would just suggest
like really going directly at it and
saying you know you may have heard from
your teacher this here's the counselor
perspective you could believe that other
teacher but here's the counsel
perspective in the data to back it up as
you see I'm like diseased so you
actually don't want to handshake but
from afar I shake your hand I appreciate
it
I thank you for coming I was wondering
about the actual like speech we gave the
authoritarianism and one of the things
that should US conservatives are usually
defined in our ideology is respect
towards the authority of traditional
institutions like family and religion
and just traditionalism in general right
in fact it's often interchangeable and
with some modes of conservatism so my
question is where would ya
where does conservator or does respect
for tradition and and authoritarianism
begin at the point of a gun is what I
would say and then the point of
silencing other people so I think that
we ought to have tremendous respect for
tradition in fact I really I said this
is someone earlier today I think the
chesterton has a great kind of
distinction between the left and the
right what he says that for the leftist
the leftist walks through a field and
sees a fence and says I don't see any
reason for this fence to be here I'm
tearing it out and for somebody who's
conservative they walk through the field
they see the fence they say I don't know
why this fence is here I'm gonna find
out why the fence is here and then maybe
I'll tear it out and I think that's the
appropriate position to take on
virtually every policy when it comes to
changing the past the burden of proof is
on you to show that making the change is
going to improve society the burden is
not on on you know the on the rule to
prove itself that said the the respect
for authority in conservatism only goes
so far right the founders were
revolutionaries who rebelled against an
existing regime and they were the
founders of what I would say is American
conservatism and in constitutional
philosophy so you respect authority
insofar as it is right but you also
don't impose from above rules that
violate basic concepts of free will and
are not in defense of life liberty or
property out so that's where the
distinction lies
all right guys it looks like to be able
time for one more question so this is
the last one so lucky Thank You Ben for
being here really enjoyed your debate at
political destroying the dead so my
question for you is I read about a
lawsuit against Harvard by Asian
Americans in 2014-15 saying that
basically agents are held to a higher
standard when being considered for
admission to Harvard that other Ivy
League schools yes
you know the stat shows that Asians have
to earn under forty points more than
whites on SATs while they don't show any
obvious lacking of you know
extracurriculars or leadership
experiences so do you think that's some
somehow and it's institutional racism
against asian-americans and if that an
army wear affirmative action really
hurts minority group which is
asian-americans yes so the short answer
is yes I think affirmative action is a
racist policy and it's in its in its
general emotion and I think that it does
particularly affect asian-americans for
a long time it affected Jews actually in
the same way there are quotas on Jews at
major universities because Jews were
outperforming the typical and therefore
Harvard Law School for a long time it
had quotas on the number of Jews that
would be allowed into Harvard
so yes Asians by virtually all the
studies that I've seen are expected to
outperform other people on the SATs in
order to in order to go to the same
schools and income doesn't seem to
matter I remember when I was in college
there's an article in The Wall Street
Journal about an Asian American kid who
grew up in a single-parent family very
impoverished had SAT points 200 points
high scores 200 points higher than a
black had similarly situated the black
kid got in the Asian didn't and that is
institutional racism because the
assumption is that if you're Asian he
must have grown up more prosperous or in
a more or more solid two-parent family
and of course that's nonsense he
everybody's an individual so yes I think
that you know when I get my
intersectional hierarchy Asians fall
very low on the intersectional hierarchy
specifically because Asian Americans
have done incredibly well as a general
group now obviously their distinctions
between Asian communities
not all people from the general
continent of Asia I have equal levels of
success in the United States you know
the their significant differences even
between Koreans and Chinese and
Vietnamese but with all of that said
overall Asians are being discriminated
against in the educational system and
that is racism well thank you so much
for having me I really appreciate it
it's good to be back home
[Applause]